is can you turn a hoe into a housewife
but in order to answer this question I
think we got to Define what is a hoe so
I want to hear from the guys what do you
guys think a hoe is
going Chris
to me
how cool a hood is
a girl that's been run through
that you know about like if you don't
know if you if you don't know she hasn't
been running through then like you can't
really you don't know honey but once you
know and it's out there like
she just has that name like you know
that you have a chance
what is what is ran through deal like is
there is it a number or is it like
yeah but
somebody that smashed oh you know a
couple people that smashed okay
okay that's a hoe I've never seen that a
number but it is
relative to age in it but if we're
talking like
near the hundreds
oh hundreds yeah like oh gosh do you
know do you know girls that are near the
hundreds
I do I'm like I don't know anyone that
slept with that many people
I well that's a girl anyway you
shouldn't be near that but if you needed
this then so so if you know like one
friend that slept with her
she's a hoe
depends on the friend okay there's some
people you're like yo like he smashed
okay
if you don't rate him yeah so if you
don't rate him and he's been there
you're like you have to be hurt
like if he's ugly or something or what
like if the guy is ugly
yeah like I mean I mean it's more of a
guy I think we just know like if you
smash
smash oh okay I'm just saying like in
general if you know that someone like
you smash them
okay we're going is that is that not
more of a is that not more of a
reflection of your male friends though
what what you think of your male friends
as opposed to the girl if you're kind of
saying if you've smashed him like
do you know what I mean
is that yeah is that is that normal not
more of a reflection of what you think
of of the guy than the girl
yeah but there's also like there's
levels
there's the latest levels too and
you can say reflection of this person
and that person at the end of the day
and if you're a hoe
you just know from both sides that
you're right
the fine words of cardi b a ho never
gets cold
there's like a whole study that was
released recently which was but hoes
don't get caught because they're like
Geordie girls up North in Newcastle
renowned for going out in kind of minus
degree weather in the shorter skirts at
the highest heels yeah no codes but
somehow they're absolutely fine don't
get cold every Southerner would be like
oh and so that someone did a whole study
about cardi B in the song saying uh that
hoes never get cold you know they can
always wear like minimal clothing right
and they don't get cold they're fine
they're doing their thing
um someone did a whole like Masters or
PhD thesis or no whatever oh goodness
but yeah so so kit what is your
definition of a hoe
um do you call them in house you kind of
struck me as a guy that wouldn't I don't
call women hoes auras
I'll be like okay you know like people
are promiscuous okay I use the uh what
Jordan Peterson would say
um
but by definition of you know the slang
of what we would call a quote unquote I
think if we go
if it goes
has quote unquote gotten around I think
she's got around like a friendship group
into that group she's going to be seen
as that she's going to be seen as that
do you know what I mean because it's one
thing to
is one thing to get around but then if
everybody knows and you're still just
acting that way then
you don't
if you then you're not fussed about your
reputation in that sense because you
because the reality is you know that
it's gonna play a part do you know what
I mean yeah so if you know that your
reputation
if you don't care about your reputation
then you're just gonna do you which is
fine each of their own but then people
are going to call you what it is do not
mean that's the reality yeah I kind of I
kind of feel like it depends on the
motive
um behind it so
like they could be a subject A and B one
could have slept with 20 and uh the
second bus got slept with 20 as well but
the way the first person must have done
it like
she could have just been guessed by her
friends and said you know what let me
just go on Mad one tonight and just just
run through 10 people at once so sorry
oh bro or the second person like they
fell for one but like they weren't too
smart in relationships so they liked one
guy and then thought he was going to
treat a nice got [ __ ] over yeah that's
another guy got [ __ ] over but the
thing is her emergency behind it wasn't
to be a whole like to run around it just
happened sort of thing so I feel like
yeah it depends on the move
interesting okay so
for the women yeah do you do you think
does sexual past matter to you in a guy
the sexual past so oh like would it like
if a guy had slept with a hundred girls
before he met you do you care no
couldn't can I swear on this by the way
yeah oh great I give a [ __ ] yeah
literally couldn't kill us yeah I don't
it's not a thing for me I don't care
especially I think if we're talking
numbers I feel like people
view sexual past
really quantitatively so really in terms
of numbers and things I don't think
that's a reflection at all of what kind
of a partner you are sexually or
otherwise I've slept with people who
have slept with loads of people who are
[ __ ] in bed I've sat with people who've
slept with minimal people and it worked
well in bed we were great whatever we
had a good relationship
so I think in terms of the quality of
the relationship you have with them
whether it's a fleeting relationship or
a lasting one I like yeah it doesn't
matter for me it's more about how
someone treats people yeah to me there's
a number where it's kind of okay I was
having this conversation if you slept
with anyone in my family cooked any of
my sisters
I feel like that's weird close friends
cooked close like immediate fret cooked
so it just anyone that you know no but I
don't here's the thing I don't have that
many friends
there's like three people who cannot
sleep with
it's not that long of a less
um but please don't [ __ ] my mom
um but I don't know like I guess if it's
extreme like if I did you can't say you
say corn instead of okay but if I got a
corn cooked like that so like to the
extreme but for the most part like I
don't really care but it's interesting
so I'm gonna ask the guys the same
question
sexual pass that the girl doesn't matter
to you
yeah
so sexual pass in the sense of if we're
in London and all right because we're
the Eastern I'll use Islam and there's
eight guys I know in East London I've
been with
it's game over right
yeah so that's all possible if if I
never knew what it did in the past and
he just came and no one knows you I
couldn't really care less
okay oh no one's here yeah you want to
feel like you you found her yeah you
don't wanna
have a goal that you know everyone
attack because then like the value of it
goes away like you don't want to treat
her the same because you know like
you're putting the effort and she she
like she gave up easy for the next man
and it's like well you're a [ __ ] in
it like you're spending this amount of
money this amount of time yeah and you
could have done less and got the same
thing yeah so yeah
and that's the interesting thing like I
think guys care a lot more about that
than girls